have you or a loved one been fired for
memes have you been canceled for bad
tweets then I have the guy for you not
me that would be crazy I'm talking about
Elon Musk Elon Musk announced on Twitter
that he'd provide financial assistance
for legal fees to users who face
backlash from their employers due to
activity on the platform if you are
unfairly treated by your employer due to
posting or liking something on this
platform we will fund your legal bill
now musk said there would be no limit to
the aid provided and encouraged all
people who have been canceled to reach
out not surprisingly he did not provide
details on the process for claiming
financial support lawyer Mark Zaid said
that this potentially created a legal
contract between musk and anyone who
seeks his help if you accept the offer
and musk refuses to pay contact us and
we'll discuss pro bono legal
representation to enforce the offer but
there are a lot of problems that might
not have created an enforceable contract
consideration vagueness bottom line
don't expect much from a billionaire
known for making Grand promises who
rarely follows through but if you need a
great lawyer for non-twitter reasons let
my firm the eagle team take care of it
the link is in the comments and the bio